well curiouser and curiouser we get more
and more strange details about the
Epstein case everyday it seems and
here's the latest reading now from The
Daily wires report it says an autopsy of
convicted paedophile alleged sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein reportedly
found that the wealthy financier had
multiple broken bones in his neck which
deepens the speculation surrounding his
death last Saturday among the bones is
that Washington Post now being quoted
among the bones broken in Epstein's neck
was the hyoid bone which in men is near
the Adam's apple
such breaks can occur in those who hang
themselves particularly if they're older
according to forensic experts and
Studies on the subject but they are more
common in victims of homicide by
strangulation the experts said the New
York Post reported on Monday that
Epstein was found hanging in his lower
Manhattan jail cell with a bedsheet
wrapped around his neck and secured to
the top of a bunk bed and apparently
killed himself by kneeling toward the
floor and strangling himself the
revelation about the broken bones that
were found in Epstein's neck followed
the revelation on Tuesday night the two
guards who were supposed to be
monitoring him fell asleep for three
hours and allegedly falsified prison
records to cover up their actions okay
now I don't want to get too graphic here
but let's imagine this for a moment
let's try to wrap our heads around it
the official preliminary story is that
Epstein hung himself bye-bye as I just
read they're tying a bedsheet around his
neck tying the other end to a bunk bed
and then leaning forward on his knees so
he was about six feet tall 200 pounds he
obviously couldn't have dropped jumped
from the bunk bed to hang himself but
they're not claiming that they're
telling us that he leaned forward this
is already hard to imagine I mean just
just really tried to imagine for a
second a 200-pound man trying to hang
himself by leaning forward with a
bedsheet around his neck the body's
natural reflex is to save itself no
matter how much you in your mind want to
kill yourself you're your
body does not want that and so your
body's gonna just as a natural reflex
there that I mean that's one of the
reasons why you can't kill yourself by
just literally strangling yourself with
your own bare hands and this is why
people usually hang themselves by
jumping from a chair or something so
that they're you know dangling there
again not to be not to be gratuitous
about but they won't be able to do
anything to regain control of their of
themselves and save themselves the point
is to successfully kill yourself the way
Epstein supposedly did would require
just I think an immense amount of
determination and effort for lack of a
better term but then you throw the
broken bones in their bones plural not
just one bone there's been a lot of
focus today on this the one bone
underneath the Adam's apple that the
that's mentioned in the report but it's
not just that but there multiple bones
broken in his neck now you heard this
happens in a small minority of cases I I
didn't read that part actually the
Washington Post noted that varying
studies varying studies have committed
suicide have found that six to twenty
five percent of them break the hyoid
bone which is one of the broken bones
and Epstein's neck so six to twenty five
percent
well that's just the one bone it would
be even smaller percentage that break
multiple bones and keep in mind that
most of those hangings presumably
involve someone who was dangling someone
who jumped from something but even in
most of those cases there isn't a there
aren't any broken bones in this case
though leaning forward with a bedsheet
around his neck I just I don't see I
don't see how that's possible I just I
don't see it I suppose I can't say it's
impossible but it's that's that's a
really hard thing to imagine now let's
take this and review all of the alleged
information as we currently know it and
let's let's let's see what explanation
as it stands right now
to be the most reasonable and we'll do
that but first a quick note from our
friends at light stream credit card
bills you know every month you get them
they're not fun
multiple payments multiple due dates
would it be easier if you just had one
payment at a lower rate you could
consolidate everything and you're paying
less money so of course it's easier we
you know it's it's this is obviously
what you need to do well now you can do
that with a credit card consolidation
loan for my friends at light stream you
get a rate as low as five point nine
five APR with Auto pay that's lower than
the average credit card interest rate of
over 19% APR the rate is fixed so we'll
never go up over the life of the loan
and just for my listeners right now you
can apply now you get a special interest
rate discount the only way to get that
discount is go to light stream comm
slash Walsh l IG HT s TR EA m.com slash
Walsh you're making things easier on
yourself you're saving money there's
there's just no reason to not do this so
go to light stream comm slash walls
subjective credit credit approval rates
include point five percent auto pay
discounts terms and conditions apply and
offers are subject to change without
notice
visit light stream comm slash Walsh for
more information all right so Epstein um
so we have these mysterious broken bones
in his neck you add this revelation to
reports that Epstein was taken off a
suicide watch as we already know his
cell mate was transferred out of his
cell the prison guards both
simultaneously fell asleep supposedly
the records were falsified and according
to some reports that were shrieking
heard from Epstein cell although it
didn't specify when the shrieking was
heard in relation to when the suicide
Abbott the alleged shows I had and in
fact if we're tabulating strange details
here in this case I think the very fact
that he killed himself is itself
arguably strange now as I said earlier
in the week you could easily see why
somebody would kill themselves in this
situation facing a life behind bars
as a child rapist especially in
comparison to life he was leading before
private jets and private islands and
everything else
so you could you could see that but then
on the other hand he had all the
leverage in the world really I mean
there are there are people more empower
'fl and important than him who he could
have flipped on and leveraged that for
something plus he'd spent decades of his
life compiling blackmail on people just
for this very reason as an insurance
policy for just this occasion then the
occasion arises and he kills himself I
don't know yeah you could say well it's
hard to know what prison would do to a
man you know if you've never been to
prison it's hard to imagine how it
changes you not that I've been you know
I sound like Morgan Freeman and
Shawshank Redemption
you can't imagine what prison would do
to a man but I mean really you can so
there's that also it's possible but but
still all of these things it's a
cumulative effect now when you look at
all these factors together you look at
the totality of thing it's beginning to
seem to me that the suicide explanation
is still possible obviously but it's
beginning to look like the most
implausible conspiracy theory you know I
originally said that the idea that
someone offed him was perfectly
reasonable and plausible but but
originally at the beginning of the week
anyway based on what we knew at the time
it seemed like the most plausible
explanation was the more banal one which
is that he really just killed himself
and was enabled to do that by the
incompetence of the government but that
was before we knew about the shrieking
about the guard supposedly falling
asleep about the falsification of
records and now the broken bones in the
neck and this to me that the broken
bones in the neck to me is very very
significant and if we're following
Occam's razor which says that the
explanation which requires the fewest
number of strange coincidences really
the explanation that requires either the
fewest it requires the fewest number of
additional explanations is probably
correct if you have an explanation where
there are a lot of other elements in
that explanation that you also have to
explain and then you have another
explanation that has fewer of those at
well then that other one is probably
correct that's kind of how
razor works and according to that it
seems that not suicide something other
than suicide is beginning to appear to
be the most plausible option because the
suicide explanation at this point
requires a whole lot of coincidences you
know it requires us to believe that a
lot of different factors just sort of
coincidentally all lined up with each
other possible but hard to believe you
know in fact if you had told me when
this story came out that the prison
guard both the prison guards fell asleep
for three hours both of them that that
was a big red flag to me if you had told
me that well no they were there and they
were checking every 30 minutes like
they're supposed to
but Epstein hung himself in between that
30-minute stretch I would have found
that a lot more plausible it doesn't
take 30 minutes to hang yourself I don't
know how long it takes couple minutes
right so if you had told me that then I
would say oh you know okay but no now
you're saying they both fell asleep for
three hours both of them that's you know
that's that's that's that's tough and
then they falsified the records I don't
know but you know my my fear is that
whatever happened we're never gonna find
out for sure especially with our
illustrious media which seems to be
losing interest in this this story I
mean this to me is definitely the
biggest story going on happening right
now in America anyway when you consider
the implications this should still be
headline news I mean this should be
leading the news broadcasts it would
seem but it's not the media is already
trying to move on from it and I think we
all know why that is when you consider
the political leanings of some of the
people potentially
who could have potentially been
implicated by a by Epstein all right
before we move on I need to tell you
something about VIN Sherrill watches but
since the biggest sale the year
happening right now with the chair
watches the more you shop the more you
save
you could save I mean literally hundreds
of dollars you could save and it's
happening right now yeah it only happens
once a year so you need to stop what
you're doing and well don't stop
watching this finish this and then get
on top of that everything on the site is
on sale right now no exclusions even the
all-new collection that just that just
dropped is available now VIN Cheryl just
dropped two new collections of watches
and a line of men's wallets as well so
it's not just watches wallets other
accessories it's all on sale the
products do sell out though though so
you don't want to wait to buy you want
to go right now go to VIN Chara watches
dot-com right now and that's how you get
the best bang for your buck with VIN
cheerio watch the thing about VIN chair
watches is there they're stylish but
they're also affordable so when you when
you're wearing the watches people aren't
going to know how much money you saved
on them they're gonna think that the
watch is much more expensive because
these are very high as far as as far as
watches and things like that go this is
the best bang for your buck that you're
possibly going to get here's an
important point they offer free shipping
worldwide so there's there's really no
excuse not to check them out again it's
VIN chair of watches comm VI NCE
RO watches comm go there right now
and save and you can look better in the
process okay the website pink news is a
prominent gay news site based in the UK
I believe they had an article in a video
up yesterday celebrating the story of
mark and Kaleb mark is 55 and Kaleb is
22 and they've been in a quote/unquote
relationship for six years and now
they're now they're getting married now
I'll let you do the math on that caleb
is 22 mark is 55 they've been dating for
six years dating again
Quotes just imagine the scare quotes
around many of the words I'm saying here
day
relationship because this course is not
relationship and it's not dating this is
grooming and and sexual abuse this means
that they started this interaction when
mark was a 49 year old man and caleb was
a minor
now pink news has since taken down the
the video on the news article but here's
a screenshot for you I'll show you I'm
sorry to subject you to this but but
there you go there it is totally normal
right totally normal for a man in his
50s to be dating a boy who was in high
school at the time when they met a you
know a guy who even now looks to be
about 12 and wears makeup totally normal
you know for for a grown man to be right
completely normal nothing we could say
about that well no it's not normal and
it's not okay but the goal is to make
this normal and I've been warning about
this for years I keep and I'll keep
warning about it because I truly believe
that the normalization of pedophilia is
the next frontier for the left we're
already there they're all there doing it
right now that's what this is not in
those words okay they're never going to
get to a point there will never be a
point where the left is saying yeah
pedophilia is okay they're gonna use
different words that's what they always
do but these kinds of stories here
they're the perfect tool for the
normalizer z' of this kind of thing
because technically and i was informed
of this seat when i was posting about it
yesterday on twitter some people say
well you know technically this is legal
but yeah i mean you put up the picture
again let's watch let's look at that
picture one more time
technically you see this right here
technically is legal technically
apparently they started quote dating
when Caleb had reached the age of
consent technically legal legal now we
all know though that even if that's
technically legal it's still sick and
gross and morally deranged and evil and
and just awful we know that we also know
that if you're a 49 year old man
sexually attracted to sixteen year old
boys who look about
10 that probably means that your
attractions well it's unlikely that your
sexual attraction just automatically
happens to cut off at the age of at the
legal age of consent you know if you're
49 year old man attracted to 16 year old
boys it's pretty unlikely that Oh 15 14
year old boys are out no way 13 no if
your attractions go in that direction
and that young it probably extends
further than the legal age of consent as
what I'm saying so this kind of story
the reason why pink News presented it to
us in such a happy and cheerful way is
that it moves society in the direction
of seeing these kinds of things as
normal and okay
of course pink news is not going to show
us a story you know about about a 50
year old man in a quote/unquote
relationship with an eight-year-old boy
they're not going to do that even if the
people who run that site would
personally have no problem with that
they're still not gonna show us that but
they're gonna do something like this
where they could say it's legal it's
just like the video I played earlier in
the week of a drag queen at a drag queen
story our teaching kids had at work
technically legal I guess or the thing a
few weeks ago of little kids at a story
our who are crawling on a drag queen
while he laid on the ground and little
children were crawling on him or the
thing where the the 11 year old drag
queen danced at a gay bar while grown
men threw money at him all of that
technically legal it shouldn't be by the
way it definitely should not be legal
for a child to dance at a gay bar I
don't think it should be illegal for a
drag queen to go to a bunch of kids and
start twerking for them I think that's
sexual harassment of children that
should be illegal too but it's not
parent Lee so the normalizer can always
hide behind that and say it's legal man
you know yeah so what it doesn't change
the fact that it's evil and it doesn't
change what what they're trying to
condition us for
and I would when we talk about
normalizing of
pedophilia and child sexual B's the
biggest example which I haven't even
mentioned is is the very fact that we're
told that three-year-old children can
choose their own gender you know the
fact that we have eight-year-old quote
unquote transgenders that's that's part
of this too because what are we saying
which I know well kids are old enough to
make these kinds of decisions for
themselves if an 8 year old boy is old
enough to decide his own gender then
then you know the next thing we're going
to be told eventually is that
eight-year-old boys are also old enough
to consent to sexual relationships we
need to the main thing I think that is
hampered the conservative movement for
years now is an inability among so many
of us to see where things are headed
which isn't to say that we all need to
be prophets I'm certainly not well we
don't need to see the future but we
should have a sense we should be able to
look at where we are now and and and we
should have an intuition of where what's
going to happen next and I think for a
long time many conservative specially
the so-called thought leaders at the
head of the conservative movement
movement have not been very good at that
and so we're constantly being blindsided
by things like this the whole
transgender thing kind of blindsided the
conservative movement where it seemed
like all of a sudden they're saying that
you know the everyone's lost their sense
of what a man or a woman is and people
can choose their own gender and I think
for a long time conservatives we're kind
of fumbling around like what's going on
how did this happen well if you've been
paying attention that shouldn't have
surprised you so 10 years from now you
know ten years from now I don't want to
hear conservatives throw in their hands
I'm say what's happening how did this
happen now that pedophilia is totally
normal and okay and you you even have
Democrats openly arguing to legalize it
don't be surprised especially if you're
not saying anything about it now don't
act surprised when it actually happens
all right before we go to emails at Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com the email
address before we do that I wanted to
make mention of this as well and I've
had this on the on deck to talk about
for a few days now Marty Sampson who is
what will was I guess a songwriter for
the Christian band Hillsong UNITED very
popular Christian band recently
announced that he's losing his faith
he's questioning things he's beginning
to suspect it seems that Christianity is
false that Jesus is not the Messiah that
I guess God doesn't exist and this is
just the latest prominent Christian to
leave the faith or or to consider
leaving the faith in the last few months
that's why this is sort of you know to
have one guy who comes out and says this
is not terribly shocking but this is
this is part of the pattern now it's
really becoming a trend or you've got
prominent pastors there was the guy who
wrote the why I Kissed dating goodbye
what was his name Joshua Harris I
believe he left the faith so it'd have
been a number in the last few months and
now we have Marty Sampson
here's we read part of what he said he
post this to Instagram he deleted the
post which I somewhat surprised he
deleted it because you said it well we
all know it I don't know what the
leading that's gonna do but so he said
in part you said time for some real talk
I'm genuinely I'm genuinely losing my
faith and it doesn't bother me like what
bothers me now is nothing I am so happy
now so at peace with the world it's
crazy this is a soap box moment so here
I go the grammars here a little bad so
little the grammar here is a little
tough so I'm going to stumble through
this okay um how many how many preachers
fall many no one talks about it how many
miracles happen not many no one talks
about it why is the Bible full of
contradictions no one talks about it how
can God be loved yet send four billion
people to a place all because all
because they don't believe a place I
assume he's talking about hell no one
talks about it Christians can be the
most judgmental people on the planet
they can also be some of the most
beautiful and loving people but it's not
for me
I am not in anymore I want genuine truth
not the I just believe it kind of truth
science keeps piercing the truth of
every religion lots of things help
people change their lives not just one
version of God got so much more to say
but for me I'm keeping it real
unfollow if you want I've never been
about living my life for others okay now
a lot of what he says and I think since
that post he's posted other things
saying that you know he hasn't left the
faith he's struggling and he's looking
into various apologists and so on
now allowed a lot of what he's of what
he says no one talks about in fact we do
talk about those things I know I do and
I have on this show the failure of of
pastors were the first thing they
mentioned said pastors fall I assume he
means all these various scandals
involving pastors and priests and other
Christian leaders that is a regular
topic of conversation among many
Christians it's something I've talked
about many times so I think that's just
not true that we don't talk about those
things alleged Bible contradictions well
with that I think I actually agree with
them that that that I think there isn't
a lot of talk about about that it's not
something that pastors generally address
from the pulpit it's not something that
Christians generally will talk about in
my experience if you're into apologetics
and you like reading apologetics and
listening to theologians and apologists
as they talk about these things
well then sure then you've heard these
those kinds of matters discussed and
addressed and explained but not on a
popular level and most Christians even
though I think they should most
Christians aren't really reading
apologetics and they're not really into
theology and so they're getting there
they're helping if Christianity is going
to come from their church from their
pastor from the people around them on
the more popular sort of level and on
that level I think that there is a
failure to address some of this stuff
including the issues with the Bible for
example why aren't pastors getting up
on the pulpit and I and maybe you'll I'm
sure I'll get emails people saying oh my
pastor does talk about it ok well then
but I think your pastor is an exception
for the most part why aren't why aren't
pastors getting up on the pulpit and
talking through say the infancy
narratives and talking about the
differences and challenges there and how
to reconcile them because if you don't
talk about it now I know the infancy
narratives in the Bible are talked about
from the pulpit quite a bit especially
around Christmas time but usually what
happens is that the pastor priest is up
there and he's and he's just giving you
the sort of standard story of Jesus that
we're all familiar with which is a
harmonization of Luke and Matthew what
you don't usually hear is a pastor get
up to say okay this is what Luke says
here's what Matthew says let's you know
here's here are the differences let's
talk through this the fact is you know
Matthew and Luke tell seem to tell
wildly divergent stories Luke has the
Holy Family going to Bethlehem for a
census Matthew has them already living
there to begin the narrative Luke has
them returning home after a visit from
the shepherds and then going to the
present Jesus and the temple then he
goes they go home to Nazareth Matthew
makes a room for a year's long flight to
Egypt to escape the slaughter of the
innocents in Bethlehem an event that
Luke never mentions and then Matthew
says that they were gonna go back to
Bethlehem implying that that was their
home originally but then the site
decided to go instead to Nazareth when
Joseph was warned in a dream that you
know it wouldn't be safe to go back
there so and so on and so on now I think
there are ways of dealing with this ways
of understanding it but the point is I I
had to go on my own and first discover
these difficulties and then hunt down
answers to them and it had you know when
I've struggled with some of the stuff or
looked at it looked into it
I've had the experience of trying to
talk to other Christians about it and
either they have no idea because they've
never studied this now I can't tell you
how many Christians don't actually know
the story of Jesus's birth and they
couldn't tell you what Luke says as
opposed to what Matthew says that's I
mean
pitiful and I admit that I was in that
camp for a long time because I hadn't
actually sat down myself as I'd let me
study this myself rather than just
taking whatever version is given to me
by someone else it's it's it's pathetic
so there are ways of going through this
but I think that these are issues that
should be addressed head-on from the
pulpit these are not issues that we
should be afraid of
so what Samson is saying here I think we
should take it more seriously than a lot
of Christians seem to be also you know
I'll just say this I've been watching
the reaction among Christians to this
you know latest Christian leader
questioning his faith and the Iraq the
reaction among some Christians
unfortunately very loud ones not all of
them probably not the majority but but
some has been in my opinion horrible
screaming at the guy that he was never a
true Christian that he's an apostate etc
etc that's not the right response here
all you're gonna do is scare him away
forever when you react though I mean
what do you think weighs when someone
says look I'm really struggling you know
I'm questioning these things and you say
yeah you then you were never a real
Christian to begin with get outta here
like what do you how what do you think
that's gonna accomplish it makes you
feel better cuz he had a temper tantrum
but is that gonna help save his soul
especially because he didn't say exactly
that he's leaving Christianity said he
was having doubts serious doubts he was
struggling his faith is dwindling and
ami claimed that he was at peace and
happy but I that the idea that's I don't
really believe that you know to have
your whole world upside down and
questioning the fundamental truths that
you that you were raised on me that
there's no way you're happy with that
that's not you don't get happiness out
of that that's a this is obviously
someone who's in a lot of emotional
turmoil the guy opened up he was honest
about his struggles in our response to
that is what to accuse him to yell at
him to get angry try to invalidate
everything he's saying as if there's no
validity to it at all as if he's as if
he's just imagining it
which is what some I I've read a few
more lengthy responses to this Marty
Sampson thing from some you know
supposed Christian you know leaders and
apologist and some of it has been Bible
contradictions sweet talking about
that's ridiculous if you knew the Bible
you would know that there are no
contradictions you idiot
I mean paraphrasing but it's kind of
been the reaction that's not right and
what he's saying you know some of these
issues here in the Bible it's it's it's
not crazy to notice them there are some
real serious issues that that are very
difficult to understand and it's not as
simple as oh yeah well you know you
can't just wave it off I mean you and
there happen you could spend your whole
life studying just the these issues with
the infancy nerves which some people
haven't you could right I mean whole
volumes have been written about it
that's how complex the issue is so when
someone says you know man I'm struggling
with this I really to wave it off and
say what are you talking about you what
you can't see how it fits together
you're idiot that's not the right not
the right response I think when someone
opens up like this and is honest about
their thought processes our response
should be okay thank you for being
honest let's talk about it let's talk
through this because I'll tell you this
if someone if people are shouted at for
opening up about their doubts and their
issues they're gonna stop opening up and
instead they're just gonna drift away
you know if that's the reaction they get
I mean I think that's probably why why
he took down the Instagram post because
the reaction was so hostile and so he
but then what's gonna happen just gonna
say you know what screw these people and
in that case I can't talk to them I
can't be honest with them I think it's
as Christians our religion cannot
function like a cult I mean that that's
the accusation here from atheists is
that we're a bunch of cultists well
we're not I mean some by some
definitions of cult then technically
every religion is a cult by some
definite but you know in the pejorative
sense when they when something Sal
you're a cult what they mean is just a
bunch of mindless drones you're being
you know you're brainwashed and all that
kind of stuff
and that of course is not true
fundamentally about Christianity but it
is true that some Christians do operate
that way
where they don't you know questioning is
not welcomed if you have any doubts then
your your your screamed at for them
people who you know stray are treated
like the enemy I mean there is some of
that and then also the the hesitancy of
a lot of pastors to address some of
these theological issues head-on from
the pulpit like the Bible you know like
the difficulties with the Bible and so
on that the problem is if you don't
address it and you're not upfront and
then so a lot of people just don't even
know that these issues exist well when
they go on their own and discover the
issues they're gonna feel like they were
lied to
they're gonna feel like you were keeping
a secret and then they're gonna start to
feel like oh I was you know they're
gonna start to feel like maybe someone
from Scientology who wakes up one day
and realizes this stuff is crazy that's
how they're gonna feel if you're not
upfront about it he brings up the issue
of you know a loving God sending people
to hell well again I mean this of course
is he's certainly not the first person
to raise this issue obviously people
talk about it but this is another one in
my experience that is not the kind of
issue that pastors will generally talk
about from the pulpit they're not gonna
talk about that they're not gonna talk
about things like how could God allow
children to die of cancer you know
things like that
yeah it's discussed but I think sort of
out on the peripherals and if you want
to engage in a discussion like that or
to get those answers you have to really
pursue them because you're not going to
get it on the mainstream level what
you're gonna get in a lot of churches is
just shallow surface level talking
points self-help life advice that kind
of thing you're not going to get these
deeper more complex discussions where
these really difficult issues are faced
head-on
and I think that's a huge mistake and I
think that's one of the reasons why
people like Marty Sampson and to
believing so we should all pray for him
all right Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com this is
from Arthur says I've lost all my
respect for you as a person Frodo from
Lord of the Rings is a hobbit not a
dwarf which you incorrectly identified
on yesterday's show a man that you
apologize for your clear prejudice
against hobbits you recant your Pro door
extremism that you denounce elves for
existing yeah you know Arthur I've
gotten so many emails from people
holding me because I incorrectly said
that Frodo is a dwarf and of course I
know that Frodo is a hobbit okay I am an
expert on Lord of the Ring just because
I misspoke doesn't mean I'm not an
expert so you don't need to lecture me I
mean there are so many great scenes from
Lord of the Rings you know I can't even
I couldn't even begin to tell you my
favorite but one of my favorites I
really like that scene and Frodo was
fighting Voldemort in the Millennium
Falcon
but then Captain Kirk comes in and he
has his lightsaber in but then the Hulk
is there and punches him and he knock
him into Batman that was a great big
scene one of the classics just great
great stuff there all right
this is from Nikolas hi Matt Nick be
from Denver I understand the vegetarian
argument however it is absurd when you
think about it two weeks ago I was
camping slash five fly fishing on a
remote mountain lake with my wife there
were thousands of mosquitoes everywhere
and more dragonflies and I've ever seen
in one place eating them each dragonfly
can eat hundreds of mosquitoes per day
while cleaning our fish I checked their
bellies and they had dozens of insects
in them as well and when I removed my
waders
I found hundreds of larvae around my
boots the the fish were eating them as
well the the point is between fish birds
and insects the amount of life ended at
this single remote mountain lake down to
the microscopic level is on an
unfathomable scale every day I thought a
Buddhist who wouldn't harm
fly probably only for that fly to get
eaten in 20 minutes later by a bird a
single cow has 500 pounds of meat on it
that's 2,000 quarter pounders when they
abstain from eating meat it has
virtually no impact on anything other
than their own feeling of
self-righteousness it has no impact on
life or the environment or the planet
even if all humans gave up eating meat
it would not change the way life works
one last point about bringing kids into
the world being bad for the environment
what is the purpose of the environment
or the planet without sentient life
without human beings there's only an
endless circle of death on the planet
doomed to be consumed by the Sun
eventually and I agree with you there
and the idea that we shouldn't have kids
because it's bad for the environment
there's no there's there's no nothing
redeeming about that argument at all but
the vegetarian argument as I said
yesterday when someone wrote in and was
was mad that I'm always so dismissive of
the vegetarian argument I said that I
think I don't think it's a crazy
argument the idea that it's you know we
shouldn't eat meat I don't agree with it
and I made a similar point to the one
that you just made which is that this is
part of the cycle of life and animals
kill each other all the time and if
you're saying that you know we are
animals ourselves and that's what a bit
vegetarians often say they say well we
have no right to go around killing
animals we're not either we're not we're
not better than them well I happen to
disagree with that I think we are better
than them and superior to them but if
it's true that we're not then we're just
part of that cycle and why shouldn't we
engage in it to blame human fur for
eating a cow would be just as absurd as
blaming a lion for eating a gazelle
right so I agree with you there and no
matter no matter if you're looking at
from an evolutionary Darwinistic
materialistic perspective or you know
theological theist perspective either
way it seems like we were made or we
evolved to eat meat and so that's fine
but I think a vegetarian would respond
and as I said it's not a crazy response
to say that ok but yeah there's a
difference between killing an insect for
even fish and killing say a cow or Pig
and it all comes down to the ability an
animal's ability to suffer and if the
these are beings that have some sort of
internal life some sort of consciousness
and they're able to suffer then it's
then we shouldn't kill them and I think
that's I think that would be the
vegetarian argument I would say well I
think we all know that a mosquito is not
capable of those kind of thought
processes however you know a pig or a
cow probably is and so and so you know
how do you square that and I also think
there's that there's also a there's a
there's a an inconsistency here because
most people who say it's okay to eat
meat we would be horrified if someone
went and shot a dog i us the dog is
being put down because it was suffering
but to kill a dog certainly kill and eat
a dog if someone were to kill and eat
their own dog
and they weren't starving but they just
felt like having it for dinner because
they were curious about how it tastes or
something we would all be horrified by
that but what's really there for the
difference between a between a dog and a
cow I don't know I can't really what why
really objectively
is it wrong to kill a dog but not
account I know subjectively we tend to
bond more with dogs than cows but as far
as the dog and cow itself their ability
to suffer their ability to feel things
and and so on are we sure that the you
know the dog really I don't know so
there is that's what I'm saying I think
there is sort of an inconsistency I
haven't worked it out completely but I
guess I just it's not an issue that I
care overly much about I don't spend a
lot of time thinking about it and at the
end of the day I think it has was
perfectly fine to eat animals although
as I said yesterday when you talk about
factory farming and when you talk about
basically producing animals just so we
can eat them and you know they spend
their whole life basically on an
assembly line you know cooped up and
cramped and everything I think some of
the stuff you hear about factory farming
is probably exaggerated but it isn't all
exaggerated and it does seem like rather
a miserable life to be you know a pig
living in a slaughterhouse right
so that becomes more difficult I think
also to to justify what you're talking
about here Nick is you know you're out
in nature you're fishing
you're camping so it's a very sort of
natural you're in nature you're part of
nature right so that's you it's much
easier to justify killing animals in
that environment as you are sort of part
of that circle of life but when you
think of it more as where we are just
produce animals to kill them and that's
the only point and we have no concern
for their suffering or anything then I
don't know it becomes harder to justify
so but I will continue to eat meat
because it tastes good so that's my
that's my moral argument it's not good
but that's it listen we can't all I try
to be consistent intellectually but we
all have inconsistencies and this is one
of mine I admit it
you asked me to give up hamburgers I
just can't do it I can't it's as simple
as that you know I'm sorry for the cows
that they happen to be so delicious and
so slow and so dumb I am sorry for them
you know I'm glad that I'm not one but
what can I do
alright we will with that very
intelligent argument on my part we will
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching and listening have a great day
Godspeed hey everyone its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show so now we
hear there was shrieking coming from
Jeffrey Epstein cell before he died and
sources say he suffered injuries more
indicative of strangulation than suicide
but we can trust our authorities and
elites to get to the bottom of this
right right we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin